citizens of the reject Nation I've got something
for you nice nice Final Destination four see
I've been doing a play on words with Final
Destination four really offers a lot Greg
they should have called it found destination
forever 45 final four is it this one called
The Final Destination yeah it is do you think
they thought it was gonna be the final destination
oh no it can never be the final destination
because I gotta milk it because that would
be sad and this is not because this franchise
has been amazing so far we're really excited
for this one thank you guys for sticking with
us thus far here's the good news we're doing
Final Destination four today here's the decent
news we are gonna do five but I'm gonna be
out of town for a minute so you might have
to wait a second for it what you can do is
subscribe and then you'll know when it is
there also while you're hitting buttons like
comment let everybody know how great my four
puns are those are all really important things
to do and thank you so much by the way to
prepper for editing this video If you guys
want more than make sure that you get our
full length Reaction watch along and sync
up with us over on patreon you guys sync up
with your own copy and that's how you do the
thing I finally learned about that too Greg
yeah that's great yeah yeah I can just tell
with how impressed you are with me and I'm
so impressed with you too Greg mostly because
Greg and John also cover several shows exclusively
over on patreon with reaction highlights and
to watch alongs included are you ready for
this I am for ready forever ready for fun
for final two fun two four Final Destination
yes let's do it
thank you [Music] all right in three two one
four four she's still one two three four yeah
that would have been better it would have
been way better but sometimes ideas come collectively
yeah that's true
uh what is this one in 3D why do you why are
you saying that because look at the credits
is that how that works this looks like they
wanted this one to be in 3D do we need glasses
no no no we we can see speak for yourself
I need glasses desperately
Gran Turismo
I I take it this one's gonna be a a NASCAR
wreck which I will say off jump is the least
relatable of all the other accidents that's
true I've only been in one NASCAR race tell
me again why we chose this overseeing the
movie if the if you guys lose focus spoken
a millisecond you have to scrape them off
the fence what's his name Greg oh my God please
don't do this again completed of course is
to see a crash you're sick don't do this again
her I know she's from One Tree Hill and also
something else and her name is Andre this
is Sophia no no no no no she's not Sophia
Bush her name is I know her very well oh [Laughter]
my God bench Brothers I'm focused on the movie
and not who the cast is
hey sport my girl use your binoculars well
they're not really binoculars exactly they're
more
that's uncouth I owned those oh do you used
to in college and in her 30s I'm not gonna
be able to help it I know both him and her
okay we will look them up after don't worry
pardon me
so annoying I guess it's more relatable if
they die uh our teens like people die watching
sports oh yeah yeah that's more relatable
than dying playing them that's probably what's
going to happen yeah [Applause]
tampons in their ears
is that gonna come back around there goes
the neighborhood [Music] was that a racist
comment I need you to move your foot thank
you [Music] I think he's a racist [Music]
I think she was in The Flash too or one of
those
motor oil oh death is on its game Chantal
oh you're still on that I've moved on is it
safe to sit here
what
okay why have all those beloved drivers died
is that common I guess
there's a crack in the foundation
this just needs to be a cool stun sequence
that's all I want
to wait yeah yikes maybe go after him yeah
run on the track
kill wall leather millwall leather is about
to make a leather wall oh everybody's skin
gonna be like everyone going down the tracks
the final is either Crystal or Chantal shake
and bake baby oh oh [__] foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
they're like going right to it
oh no that's gonna be brutal no that's Sharp
[Laughter]
oh no this happens in life yeah you know if
you're in a stampede situation you want to
make sure that you keep your backpack on and
make yourself as big as possible you listening
to me I could have just saved your life
this one's super CGI
3D movie
so which one of them do you think is getting
the Visions it's the guy the guy who got the
Beloved yeah that saw the come on
whoa see that pipe it's in 3D it's right at
me
oh you see the trajectory the characters go
guy girl guy girl cowboy in a hat he sits
here pardon me she gets tampon she puts him
in her kids ears it's a lot of tampons for
one woman
men are so stupid sometimes [Laughter]
thank God what no no I got 500. I want to
see the 10 minute short film where they where
they just let it happen oh we gotta go right
now
we didn't spend any time at all getting to
know the characters that's like one of the
build up things you got to do there's always
wood crash yeah the security guard is somebody
we know too yeah it's Bubba from Forrest Gump
my wife
[Music]
that's death came for her anyway
[Music] oh this is the first time the credits
are after yeah
no that she changed her last name my new Chantelle
Christ a Allen too interesting okay this is
your bliss right now this is bliss did you
say this is your bliss yeah I couldn't be
happier that I was right about her name David
Rapaport yes casting let's go David and Lindsay
I love them this isn't an audition Roxy
oh I think these are deaths from the older
movies
yeah yeah these are definitely other ones
what gave away the train yeah
by caffeine all right challenge accepted our
Amusement Park's going the way of the dinosaur
did you see that sign that was an Easter egg
that was the subtitle on screen because of
what happened last time yeah but why are we
still alive who cares why if we made it we
deserved it he's my favorite character keep
him alive I think you're as well
oh
McKinley Speedway McKinley McKinley is the
name of the high school yeah yeah and the
guy I can't go back there Lori yeah screw
that I mean the least we can do is pay our
respects to those people the people people
didn't have a doctor Xavier with them to tell
him to get out of the way it's an X-Men reference
good one kiss it it's your choice heads or
tails but you know I like head [Laughter]
something gave us a second chance so this
feels like a CW Show yeah it really does it's
giving Riverdale like the line about had underrated
though his one-liners so far about tampons
and underrated yes yes I think they're excellent
you've been able to gather the scope of that
line about it to qualify it as not enough
people have talked about this line yes you
heard me
that kid whoo you know what I like about this
one so far they're just like let's just go
through all the [__] they know how this
goes speed it up yeah I think that's a problem
we don't need to build up here I wanted to
thank you you're a hero because of your warning
we're alive and our two sons are safe look
is she tampon on the ears lady how did you
know what was going to happen look we're just
glad you all are okay thank you the music
is the dramatic hey it's it's nice to see
people actually being like hey you're a hero
instead of what are you pretty freaked out
about that back there I just wanted to ask
you how you uh killed my wife okay okay there
it is like the McKinley dude we need that
character to go in there after but you uh
I'm sorry for your loss oh he was getting
racist earlier right yeah yeah nobody lives
forever whoa it's time for you to leave sir
times damn koi genre could have played that
guy based on oh nothing
that was the most disparaging where do I know
the this detective guy from Bubba from Forrest
Gump no I know him from something have you
not seen Forest no I have I know I'm from
a TV show third the third watch here's a Josh
Third Watch it's an NBC show
whoa It's coming right at me okay I know the
problem that happened with this movie they
made it too much for 3D and they got way too
caught up in the gimmick this seemed real
relaxing about
doing it right here this franchise is good
at hot people though
sign
it's been a long time since I've watched a
movie where I heard somebody call somebody
the n-word that was like just truly shocking
yeah it was have you heard uh koi casts McCoy
genre
quickest ways to make an audience dislike
somebody depending on who that audience members
yeah I guess the Right audience hey Ma it's
late what are you doing up no no no say turn
on the TV yeah it's fine Alcoholics Anonymous
and the wisdom to know the difference
have we had any hints about how the guy inside
is gonna die
no Red Cross is he like a KKK member
maybe he's gonna die right now I hope we kill
him off early but does he deserve it Roxy
yes oh okay
he's digging a grave from no to put the cross
in there better don't you know how it goes
oh oh
maybe death wasn't supposed to kill yeah yeah
maybe death is Against Racism
like this is the first time we're seeing death
be like nobody isn't his time it's your time
what the hell is happening he was trying to
kill somebody else but that person wasn't
supposed to die yet you gotta catch on fire
oh my God foreign [Music]
damn yo this one is so weird when you're something
freaky ironic I've seen that door before you
have that is freaky yeah in his nighttime
vision his nightmare you caught that
it's coming right at me this is like acting
out of a late night Cinemax movie I don't
think it was a dream it was like a vision
I mean there were their flames and bad continuity
I was just saying the same thing like you
can't just imagine her mouth come on man prepper
does a better job yeah prepper it was like
I saw Clues as to how he was gonna die just
now I saw another one what is with the continuity
Hunter looks so they can't match it up ever
since I left the racetrack I feel like there's
something in the room with me
this sword is so B movie schlocky
I be lying if I said I wasn't enjoying it
I bet you can't hit that song with rock okay
oh these are the two kids with the tampons
all right death let's see what you do
gasoline smoking a cigarette this guy's an
idiot Richard's out today so my appointment
is there someone else that can see me please
um look at this ah thank you so much didn't
she go on a date with Joey once When Rachel
and he was trying to after Rachel and him
had their friend date and he started falling
in love with her and then didn't go on a date
with her and he like turned to look at her
watch her walk away and he's like nah you're
not a friend long enough oh I've only told
him to fix it like I'm really fine
hey oh no oh I don't want to watch until it
happens like that they do know how to do that
yeah like set you up for something disgusting
yeah
I already wanna hear it
oh boy no Nails oh that is the worst second
would be teeth yeah
yeah it's gonna fall
honestly I'm okay with being the fan the grease
whatever but not the toe the toenail is gross
do you think
see I don't like this stuff where it just
looks like death is just moving [__] with
its hand oh it's sliding on the water is it
though it looks it kind of just looks like
death is pushing it
honestly seriously as long as it's not the
toe yeah I could watch anything stab her eyes
for all I care
oh
Sizzle sizzle [Music] I'm so sorry it won't
happen again over to a different chair
oh is this just one giant fake out sorry about
this boys come on oh no let's go she's gonna
walk outside and the rock is gonna hit her
you think so yeah you're right
whoa I on YouTube as long as it's not a toenail
don't you think it's just a little weird that
two of the people Nick saved are now dead
weird is putting tampons in your kids ears
the night before it happened Nick had a really
strange dream I feel like I'm just watching
a series of events I'm not watching an actual
movie right now and I realized that I actually
seen how the next person was gonna die we
stayed up Googling premonitions Vision signs
there are tons of articles about people every
Survivor died and the precise order they were
meant to die in the accident but we survived
so now does that mean we all die you're catching
on sweetheart this feels like a really well-lit
student film is it really well lit I mean
I'm saying if this was a student film I'd
be like this is well lit and that would be
my compliment I'm just saying he could be
watching a ton of TV you know what this stuff
does to me Janet it's okay what does it do
to you makes her very anxious Greg why do
you gotta be a prick all the time she saw
somebody die right in front of her so did
we yeah and we're all freaked out really you
you seem so unaffected if you're right about
this whole crash thing then I'm going to make
the most of every moment I have left I'm gonna
go get laid if I'm dying I'm trying his lines
are saving this whole movie if I'm dying I'm
trying probably just some weird coincidence
this guy's way too chill if you're dying you're
trying at least hook up
what does it keep saying in there it's here
how we gotta go to the racetrack
the way the Visions are shot this time that
3D thing is just not Landing it's not creative
the way they're doing it it's it's just like
he just has a vision of how it's going to
go down and there's no like solving you know
this is the only thing that I can think of
to help me remember the order okay so he he's
figured out the order such all right you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna focus on what's
good about it watch this happen what's good
about it is looking people yes dimples and
that racist and his wife we killed the racist
you killed the racists or his tick tocks as
we unalived the races maybe this was a really
bad idea no no I gotta try yeah you've got
you better have a damn good reason for trespassing
I just need to remember the order young man
that sounds crazy yep maybe this will help
you did you just say young man that sounds
crazy maybe this will help you
McKinley Speedway was there any McKinley in
the first two there I have no clue that's
for that guy in the mechanic jacket dies Adam
Sandler light that collapse kills hunting
Janet and that's when you die and then Lori
and me man they got such a high like he's
such a great actor they got him to be in this
maybe if we can stop this mechanic from getting
killed we can break the chain and the rest
of us will all be safe no negative no his
name we know nothing about him but we do know
where he works Grand State custom yeah smarty
tell me they have her in heels I pray to God
they have her in heels
well what are you doing trying to find you
you think this guy looks like Adam Sandler
yes you don't no they're now dead I'm sorry
looks like his brother
[Music] [Applause] Emma said it's porno acting
well you literally already said that oh I
did did I Cinemax after dark oh yeah yeah
I did watch it naughty die like in front of
me I want to see her feet I lost my wife and
my daughter in a car accident and he escaped
death I was drunk he escaped death today I
asked myself how come it couldn't be me oh
he caused death I was actually destroying
their memory so now I try to live each day
in their name that's the stuff you don't like
this this this this thing is pace so weird
I'm around dangerous equipment every day if
I was meant to die would have happened by
now um
I guess it's not my turn to die
whoa that was gnarly cool oh looks like cake
we have to warn your friends which one is
next look they both die in the collapse I
don't know think Focus I really feel like
this is the first time they cast people off
of their looks or do you think it's just the
directing not being able I mean I've seen
her in several things and she's she's so good
okay so it could just say it all right and
like honestly struggling with that because
she's really effing talented
this movie is a market improvement over the
last three no we've got boobies in all movies
I don't know about all of them but this one
and last one this is like an 80s horror sequel
is he a lifeguard no maybe I don't think so
lifeguards were red right he's your type that's
actually the rudest thing you ever said to
me and so categorically false laughs the other
guy's more my type that was so fast it's almost
as if I hit a trigger point God damn it I
win that Mom thanks have a nice day let's
see what we got here brownie I swear to God
if anything happens to that dog Penny that's
some [__]
that's like a that was huge close your door
yeah
wait don't look up you're driving
what are you trying to do my custom piece
of [__] you're driving honey what are
you trying to do it's red light red light
red light red light clear clear oh damn that's
an Easter egg
[Music] all right
listen to me buddy listen no water okay stay
away from water how can you stay away from
water when he's having sex at the pool I know
I mean this is a death or thrisking right
I mean come on yeah if I'm dying I'm trying
I mean he's succeeding messages marked urgent
give me the gun oh no this is the man you
said was my type and I'm right
Greg take it back no no no no no no no
don't kill him off he's the best part of the
movie he he does have the best one-liners
oh wow that's how you drain the pool that's
a strong strong plastic gun right there death
had to pull on gravity in that moment
he's always doing this coin thing I know it's
one of his ticks he's a character actor oh
people are always so afraid of the pool drains
I wonder oh what's gonna happen it's time
to make some predictions Roxy what's gonna
happen yeah suction to it and drown I don't
know how Car Wash death do you that I think
car washes are like the hottest place on the
planet I hope you know I I thought you might
have thought
obviously it's for people's minds go is that
true no who the hell thinks that I don't know
sometimes when you're in there and it's like
all the colors and stuff I'm like oh yes this
is the most seductive place right here I kind
of think so okay please at home tell me I'm
right
let's see if this prays in any fears because
I do like to go to the car wash I do too because
it's hot it's the hottest place on the planet
man you don't think this is sexy I guess it's
like loud I don't know
what is your qualifications
it's dark it's mysterious it's wet
what is she honking at uh she's trying to
get the attention of uh person there I'm gonna
give the movie credit there I would have honked
the horse try to open her door why are you
trying to open your door so you can get out
of the situation Car Wash you can't
is she gonna drown in her own car I mean that's
hot to some people man
pure sex oh my gosh you know I see it now
and I will be yo where are we now oh okay
obviously a country club Greg oh it's coin
what's gonna happen to get sucked in there
yeah he goes to get it and he gets sucked
in yeah he's gonna drown him why is this coin
have so much meaning to him I don't know what
he's gonna go try to get it it went down there
oh don't do that yep knew it I called that
take your pants off take your shorts off take
your shorts off or it could just drown I feel
like she could have climbed out of there yeah
me too maybe it's gonna close on her head
oh yeah oh now it's moving
oh that sucks yeah that is a good one that
sucks
oh Jesus would that hurt
it was a well done one
get her out oh no oh no what's gonna happen
oh she wasn't next I know take your shorts
off because he's your type that's why I want
you to your shirts take your shorts off
it just like sucked him in yeah that was a
little bit of a stretch all of him I'm next
George you can't give up unless you do she
was good in other things I'm telling you
enjoy that one no he's an alcoholic oh geez
Roxy who's the racist now I forgot he was
reading it my bad I was just like yeah we
could use a good glass of wine Honestly though
if you're an alcoholic and you know for sure
you're gonna die oh man dude do some coke
man just do it all at this point it's not
my actual suggestion care what happens we
are in this together this feels like when
a director casts himself in something and
that's why they got this kind of lead that'd
be unique uh yes they were saved through action
they were saved does it that's it no this
is action on potholes no through action they
were saved with the parts that were in the
knots filled on oh I think yeah I caught that
too reaction car washes are sexy yo am I right
or am I right cheerleaders are at car washes
or something bikini while she's talking about
it's a regular dress every time I'm in there
by myself I'm like I wish somebody was in
here with me man
oh no no George you're the best actor in the
film man come on providing weight I really
don't think this is the actor's prom fault
I think he's the best one in the film George
no I knew it George I didn't say it out loud
but I knew it oh my God oh my God a bottle
of painkillers I just threw them up then I
went to the garage hooked the hose from the
tailpipe stuck it inside the car the car kept
rolling he's not next saving Janet must have
destroyed the list then no I think congratulations
are in order and theoretically is a cool shot
we've been given a second chance you guys
going to do with it they miss you
this one is so goofy maybe it's time to stop
talking about doing stuff and actually start
doing it through action I live once right
no he forgot about somebody else's death who
could it be it's like they don't care at all
about their friend that died in the pool in
all fairness I guess they're not positive
it was him they must have learned by now Amsterdam
here we go you know Janet is so incredibly
jealous all right well tell her I said hi
I will this movie is completely void of emotions
I'm I am curious where we're going you are
that's a genuine feeling you're having yeah
okay
oh my God Satan
the unknown survivor of the McKinley Speedway
crash has finally been named Jonathan Groves
was rescued in the rubble he's next that's
the light reason remember that guy who sat
in front of me in the racing with the cowboy
you didn't die all right which means he's
next but just be there in five all right I'm
on my way did a completely different team
make this movie so he sees him die in the
shower or this you feeling okay Mr suvi you
know how many of your kind I killed in Korea
I'm Chinese pt3 right now okay and I do mean
that okay there's a strange racist Spirit
about this one yeah it's like unnecessary
[Music] oh somebody help is it so we don't
care when he dies that they made him racist
also I guess that might be the best I think
they're trying to add personalities oh but
so he's above them yeah I don't think the
old guy's gonna die
it would be that would be so confusing like
what is happening I made it out of the rubble
and now
you know you guys warned us I'm waiting for
like something to be new and Innovative like
how they figure out how the person you know
how we had like the photos from the last time
or there was the connection the time before
to the first movie like we need something
hit us with something I think we just keep
an eye out for any signs in danger I think
we got a shot okay let's just go find Lori
and Janet it's like deja vu my wife say that
Deja Vu was like God okay no
oh
nice five it is shocking how much of a downgrading
quality of store of of a movie it is I have
like 80 theories on how and why yeah shoelace
that [__] is stuck her kicks are stuck
but she's not supposed to be sneaks or stuff
shoelaces stuck oh oh help me get it out take
your shoe off okay green screen what is she
next pushing my ankle out
you okay Nick's gonna think you're so unattractive
now yeah your sneaks are totally destroyed
where are we that that was just a fire in
the sand I don't know I feel like they cut
to a lot of random spots theater 13 second
toe on your left 13's an unlucky number for
many people it's only the three of them left
yeah and I haven't given a [__] about
anyone yeah where is um Tony Todd yes it wasn't
even around the last one it's here
oh my God I think that they're gonna die in
the theater what gave you that clue well I
could pick up on subtle details really well
oh is this like a happening above the theater
remember the nail gun death another one or
the nails through that person's head that
was gnarly
the deaths in this one been death by water
in the pool hey man you might be onto something
with the elements you know honestly the elements
came back you might be honest I thought you
would yeah dude you're on dude now cut them
off what are they watching [Music]
I was like an AMC commercial whoa whoa this
is a weird advertisement do you remember when
Nick said that he could see signs before something
bad was gonna happen now I think I'm seeing
them it's just so Hollow it's like even if
I didn't believe my friend if they said that
I'd be like let's go home this is a movie
who cares really I'd be like we covered all
this time and money
I feel like you drive home Roxy you make us
sit on the aisle anyway oh boy that's the
difference between me and you Greg that and
the whole car washed the buckle who are you
in here Nick
oh good she's right there George is dead
damn it we gotta go come on no wait I was
meant to see this movie [Laughter]
yeah you are you were but how could she have
died next that really defeats the order why
why who was supposed to die next Chantal really
yeah because we skipped her already when she
was in the water from the her car right we
skipped her after she was already supposed
to die she got crushed at the same time as
her boyfriend then they were both in those
water accidents but we saved her from the
water accident so we're supposed to skip her
I'm on your side
there's a lot of massacres in this one foreign
that's that's different that's Creative
Murder her oh my God Crusher
flatten her
that means Deja Vu my wife said that Deja
Vu is like God's way
all right I'll give the movie some credit
man that was good that was good but we're
gonna do that whole thing I mean he's gonna
prevent this but goodbye I didn't think that
was did you see that coming but what I I don't
really get I don't really get it oh okay just
give me something I feel good whatever what
I'm taking my wins at this moment
I'm playing buddy why'd you call the fire
department man why don't you call the fire
department
damn it
foreign
I think he should have been the first one
to die now they don't care about the order
oh where's that one thing gonna fly to
We Didn't Start the Fire Fall Out Boy
thank you you can get out of that
oh I want to see him fail
yeah it's kind of hard to tell who I'm rooting
for I want to see them all die
oh my God it's like it's right it's Friday
coming right at me
fire alarm or what I've been thinking about
what I'm gonna eat after this movie is done
the whole time what are you thinking my Lean
Cuisine Pizza oh my God he saved the day
two weeks later isn't it supposed to be screwed
tighter you're right tell you what we'll get
somebody on that pays to be safe man trust
me
that was a commercial I don't know for what
but is this his character Arc I love you whoa
is that a real background this actually just
got it did you wear yeah uh there's a place
right next time
all the places people have died see you again
race cars we're putting it all together Greg
and the background what if we didn't change
anything oh no beep right now
[Applause]
Mortal Kombat
oh what it's all happening in X-ray vision
no these are the credits
well that happened okay so Bobby campo's the
name of the guy you're talking about yeah
I'm curious if I'm gonna go follow him on
Instagram right now yeah Chris Allen is good
um yeah so we just watched Nation four and
here's what I'll say the people the people
were right the people were right on this one
people were Wicked right yeah that was um
I just can't believe we got one two and three
and then this is what followed was this directed
DVD I mean that honestly no it was clearly
in 3D in the theaters it is clearly made for
that yeah I know you're right you're right
the thing is though it wasn't miserable to
watch and by any means for me what was it
for you I think uh if we if I if I was at
home by myself I would have turned it off
relatively quick bummer would you no you would
have finished it I think I would have started
cooking dinner oh she would have just half
paid attention yeah you ever do that or you're
watching something and you're like man so
you just like start I would have second screened
it or started cooking dinner like I still
I love the premise of these movies so there
are still interesting moments the main issues
I had were that I didn't love the kills in
this one the dialogue was a was challenging
I didn't know or care about any of the characters
uh and there was no there is no aha moment
like I guess at the end here with that you
hold that yes I I captain and uh all full
of stuff all right all right what am I pulling
up um go to IMDb all right let's mouse pad
me all right let's uh what's happening here
we're gonna look up some stuff I wanna okay
type the final two final destination the final
okay no we got okay here we go is this one
right yep 2009 it's a year I graduated high
school so they got the I think that their
um wardrobes were great okay the directions
they were accurate the director was David
Ellis all right I'm looking him up and he
also has directed the likes of uh don't worry
I'm gonna make school go back up what's he
known for go back up he's known for Matrix
Reloaded oh he was a second unit Shark Night
cellular Snakes on a Plane he was a director
okay so he does it's like some plans like
schlocky B movie entertainment cellular wasn't
too bad have you seen cellular no what is
it it's the one with Chris Evans and he's
trying to save Kim Basinger uh she's been
kidnapped by Jason Statham okay so where's
this like directing credits okay mainly did
stunt work we'll click on the directing that's
kind of disappointing I mean he's mainly done
stunt work click on the top yeah and then
um Asylum okay I did Snakes on a Plane before
this I told you that he directed Final Destination
two really no [__] that is shocking what
was the budget for this one even though it
there was like more it seemed like it might
have been a bigger budget the budget seemed
so tiny during some parts and with that's
where so quickly hit some of the car and then
done all right type in final test Nation
production budget all right all right you
got it okay 20 no that's the that's the gross
okay here we go buy 40 million dollars that
was fun that cost 40 million I could see it
with the 3D and all that stuff yeah man yeah
wow they got the director the second one and
this is what turned out that's shocking that's
truly shocking what I need to do something
wrong I have some research what went wrong
with this movie okay hold on I need to do
this I told you what she was in she was in
One Tree Hill and she was very good in that
the flash yep I was right on about that I'm
a brilliant brilliant person now I need to
know about okay this other dude what does
he do afterwards Bobby Campo that's the guy
that okay he was in Legally blondes okay so
he didn't work much after this movie as uh
you kind of predicted which is interesting
I really don't feel like this was his fault
but okay and then no no no there's a lot wrong
and then Michael T Williamson I know from
what he's done like a billion things yeah
I know I know yeah for sure I just know that
I saw him in something recently that he was
very good in oh species too no Free Willy
no it's none of those oh fences yeah okay
all these things yeah okay I've seen him in
like a thousand a thousand things yep good
talk yeah good talk good commissary well you
told me to do this and this so I'm doing this
did I say for you to do do this no you told
me to do this yeah this is why women are written
mad in these Final Destination movies because
these attitude well I'm just mad because you
got mad first oh that makes sense yeah um
okay let me ask you this question and I want
you to try to answer it as non-sarcastically
as you possibly can I can do that [Laughter]
word what did you like about this movie I
liked the car wash scene because it was hot
yeah yeah way to keep up the non-sarcasticness
con area Susan Connor I like the car wash
scene I like the scene where um actress you
claim is amazing guys in the elevator in the
escalator Chantel but I'm telling you she
changed her last name um I mean maybe she
got married and uh changed her last name yeah
I think so and uh you really like I I think
here so that way we can just uh pull it out
and I don't know she didn't change her last
name it's still Advanced sand but I don't
remember that being the case uh she's still
attractive yeah she's really cute oh yeah
she's still attractive yeah a full show she's
very good I'm telling you she's in the boys
yeah she's she's uh butcher's wife yeah yeah
the mom but she is a great actress she is
I'm telling you yes I really think she's super
soft oh my God yeah no I thought she was great
in that show yeah that's why I'm saying cared
about her character a lot I really feel like
we cannot judge any of these actors based
on this because okay yeah no you're right
you're right she's really good she was in
The Flash yeah she's very good okay I feel
bad for her because in this she genuinely
doesn't seem like she knows what she's doing
okay that's got to be the director or the
the dialogue just type in okay oh hold on
let's go to the trivia here in the Final Destination
I gotta know the name of the blonde dude because
I know him too okay Nick Sano yeah click on
him what is he in is it 90210 or what's his
deal I've seen him and something we're uh
DC's Legends of Tomorrow Hayward no of course
he's Nate Haywood that was so stupid of me
oh I told you it's all the CW people which
makes sense because David Rappaport passes
he does all the CW shows yeah oh maybe we
shouldn't be so insulting then Krista Allen
is the one that you recognized Krista Allen
her characters literally milk yeah and she
is she's a total MILF she's a stand-up comic
anger management Baywatch she was in an episode
of Friends I guarantee it and the fact that
you can't recall this no I think you're right
but I can't remember exactly wait you missed
it where she was anger management no no oh
wait no it said Feast okay yeah I got you
I wish you guys could see what we're trying
to do here did I type I can't see anything
no delete you put friend
just leave it there all right all right hit
enter yeah Fable okay so what's the episode
the one where what it was the one where him
remember what the no more Joey dates Rachel
yes right you're gonna tell you that yeah
yeah I know exactly what you're and then she
doesn't look the same I mean I guess she's
younger there he goes on a I mean it's only
been a few years unless you're saying something
about women just age significantly within
a few years that's kind of mean and sexist
Roxy women get better as they get older I
couldn't even say that with a straight face
Jesus everybody knows that men are like a
fine wine and women are like that is just
not a hint of sincerity there people okay
we're going back can you let's rewind let's
go back to the things you liked about this
movie I liked the 3D it really popped did
you like any character God no they were all
awful the characters were tough in this one
tough what what do you mean tough you like
they were like strong no no it was like oh
man that was tough tough Oh I thought you
were like these were all stronger no they
were tough to like you know like they really
oh no they were terrible Michael T Williamson's
character was the most easy to like he was
really trying yeah yeah he was really trying
it just and and it just it felt like just
a series of events just strung together with
no real direction as they were making this
movie their transitions were bizarre with
the flashes like of the 3D what's happening
yeah it just felt really piecemeal and like
although I did just ask us to talk about what
we liked and I just was not capable of staying
on that I at one point said during the reaction
I'm gonna focus on only the things that I
liked that I don't think I succeeded for even
a minute but the the they're not a complaint
I've had where I'm like oh I really want them
to kind of feel affected by when a death happens
yes this is especially didn't they would it
was like every next scene was a reset of just
hey we're back to being normal like right
away I I could I just really couldn't care
like blonde boy was sucked into the pool system
gut scores come out his coin and you guys
were all like it's over it was like what bro
that was not well done okay I'm trying to
see we all know he liked Ted and then he ended
up having no head yeah and then one girl almost
got her head cut off I do think the uh the
car wash scene was actually well done what
happened with the kids of the MILF I think
they lived I like the car wash scene too the
lowest rate IMDb thank God yeah and then they
just said this is the one that Tony Todd's
schedule conflicted with which is a bummer
because he I do like when he's in these okay
I look just just what are you looking at just
type in what went wrong with Final Destination
for
okay okay are we going to the Cesspool that
is Reddit or what do you think in here there's
got to be like something that happened with
what went wrong with putting this together
because right yeah I mean it would like was
it a different um was the writers different
than any other movie okay yeah let's start
there
it is it's baffling yeah I know absolutely
baffling I Am with You of what okay we're
gonna get down to the bottom of this okay
look all I gotta do is go to this guy oh and
we're just on Nate Haywood's um thing we were
watching Sarah Lance get married it was really
beautiful I'm sorry okay well yeah like okay
so you know it's directed by the same guy
who directed the second one but it's written
by Eric Bress and Jeffrey Reddick okay Eric
breast okay he wrote Final Destination two
and he wrote The Butterfly Effect what I just
can't determine what happened the same team
behind two did this one that is baffling to
me there's got to be they had a big enough
budget they're the same team they had quality
actors I'm telling you
yeah I I I just can't get over like the um
I can't get over what happened here hmm all
right there's one last section I have to check
what is it go to yourself before you wreck
yourself no okay there's no room for jokes
now Roxy go to Wikipedia oh really there's
usually there's like facts about the production
process okay type the Final Destination okay
all right you good you good an American 3D
supernatural horror film all right development
all right read aloud for the kids at home
if I find something interesting I will read
aloud James Wong was on board to direct but
he was he directed Dragon Ball Evolution oh
man so that scheduling it to drop out this
feels like Dragon Ball Evolution so so Ellis
accepted because of the three day Harry said
it was Perry Perry who the [__] is Perry
Craig Perry was a producer okay Craig Perry
art the producer oh the guy who commented
he said he wanted to add depth to the film
instead of just something popping out of the
audience every four minutes
I guess wouldn't that be not a good reason
to do 3D ah yes I'm confused by the sentence
he accepted because of 3D for the 3D Perry
said he wanted to add depth to the film instead
of just something popping out of the audience
every four minutes
can we do an interview where we get perion
to talk to us about it yeah I'm like I gotta
ask you man I just want to know what happened
with this movie because like so filming the
shooting was it should be done in Vancouver
where the previous ones were filmed but the
this one was shot in New Orleans okay so they
were working in a different location there's
nothing really here that that says when he
commented on the video didn't he say like
there's a lot of [__] that went down or
no am I making that up uh I don't know oh
you texted it to me so let's read it no yeah
let's read it yeah okay let's read it yeah
much less a review and more of just us we're
just trying to investigate what the hell happened
this is what Kirk Perry wrote To Us allegedly
we I mean I guess we don't know that it's
him but he says it is this just popped up
in my feed nice having produced all the Final
Destination movies I appreciate your reaction
and in general I agree on almost all your
points there was a lot of figuring this out
as we went along we also re-shot the ending
while beefing up certain elements throughout
all the sequences you mentioned the budget
which was 23 million back in 1999 when it
was shot but the very advantageous exchange
rate for Canadian currency at the time we
shot in Vancouver brought the budget to 31
million I do hope you watch the rest of them
outside of fd4 I think they're all well executed
and entertaining fd5 in particular was a real
return to form it may be my favorite of the
bunch thanks again for watching okay so he
just said I hope you watch the rest okay so
he doesn't like he was even saying skip four
yeah he says outside of fd4 I think they're
all well executed entertaining because yeah
this one right off the bat the biggest the
problem that I had with it was the build up
of the sequence of events in the in the opening
NASCAR race because it didn't you like the
other ones had a very it's a very simple structure
you get to know the characters beforehand
you get invested and you watch this this Ripple
of effects and then bam the big incident happens
right the premonition moment and here it was
just like rushing through everything I'm like
I have no idea who these characters are I
could care less there's no tension at all
being conveyed whatsoever and then it felt
bogged down and and CGI gimmicks or even like
the roller coaster event in part three which
must have had CGI there I mean there were
obvious parts of it that felt CGI but that
even felt more tangible that even felt more
real than the NASCAR stuff that went down
which is just in a crowd you know that is
on ground and not on a removing roller coaster
like them being upside down on the roller
coaster felt way more like oh my God than
anything that happened here and this is something
where I felt this should have been easier
to capture and it just kind of kept moving
at Whiplash Pace without and it's just felt
so empty of emotion and on every regard like
there was such a lackadaisical quality to
the way all this went down the relationships
were challenged like the lack of chemistry
kind of between the friends where the two
girls Lori and whatever her name was they
didn't seem to like each other that much and
then the couple um the girl from the boys
and her man they she says that's my cowboy
but like what was the dynamic there and then
the guy friend of theirs it completes the
four the they didn't care that he died yeah
so that was challenging too yeah I think that
this one just missed the mark from script
to execution I don't it's hard to blame like
one specific area because it feels like there
was a lot of holes yeah but again I still
Greg I'm not just saying this because we're
doing this reaction I'm not kidding you I
still had an enjoyable time throughout kind
of because the premise I like and and I did
say at one point I'm curious what happens
here I was never curious yeah it's gonna happen
I was I was you seemed like you were actually
intrigued at times yeah you go like how are
they gonna solve this what's like you the
game was enough for you at times and for me
I was I kept losing interest as it came it
wasn't even it's so terrible it it's good
you know what I mean it wasn't even it didn't
even quite Broach there where I felt if if
it had at least done that it was just like
questionably bad and it was kind of breaking
my heart because I thought the third one might
have been the best one so it's a good to go
down with you especially in uh Retros back
in hindsight the third one's my favorite yeah
yeah that one well maybe the fifth one though
like what do you what do you think obviously
they can do differently than this but what
are you hoping to see is there an opening
prediction that you have like what what kind
of scenery we could be in I mean setting scenario
scenery it's a beautiful sunny day
here's my favorite thing I liked about it
too is not having not having any bit of familiarity
with it at all I mean I didn't really like
the I I think the the thumbnail for Final
Destination 3 gave away the roller coaster
event right yeah but Heroes I have no idea
what's gonna happen whatsoever so that was
fun um but I don't know what the well what
the fifth one be it has to be some type of
crazy disaster we've done plane maybe they
could be on set right something goes wrong
on set like it goes that meta and maybe I
don't know people say the fifth one's amazing
so I'm looking forward to that yeah what are
you what are your final thoughts on the final
destination for um good good yeah oh yeah
final thoughts that yeah I think one thing
they had to nail too was the deaths and they
did not nail the deaths you're right about
that because I feel like the deaths were designed
to have some moment that had a 3d effect instead
of really packing a true punch the best death
in this one was the car wash and it wasn't
a death yeah that had the most tangibility
and and uh like that one you could really
feel like oh this there's something about
this I can latch on because it's relatable
we all go through the car wash and I think
that that's lack that like the dentist really
stood out to us because we I've been there
before you've been there before roller coaster
all that kind of stands out this was like
sometimes with the race car and the uh just
I don't know it was not as like poignant yeah
good good and the uh I like the elevator the
escalator of death it wasn't real I still
thought it would look cool I thought that
was cool yeah but that's our favorite ones
are the ones that didn't happen Oh you mean
it wasn't real by it was just a premonition
yeah that's true and I thought they copped
out with that x-ray [__] at the end too
yeah kind of too I know what you mean yeah
yeah if you see them get in them x-ray x-ray
but we did open that way um okay well that's
final destination form we're gonna do five
please be patient with me in my little schedule
I'm gonna get back here as soon as I can how's
that cap taste it's not yours right I don't
know not anymore I think it's your bio freeze
man oh it is my Biofreeze cap yeah is your
tongue turning down huh no no no no no do
you want some no no I just you want some cap
I'm good I'm all set of the cap um thank you
guys for being here and a special thank you
to somebody right yeah the man who introduced
Roxy to the car wash that person deserves
a shout out okay next time you see Roxy go
to a car wash you make sure to get in line
behind that would have been a good song prediction
take get your car wash day it's a song
better okay that's a a prediction I don't
know what song you were doing hey get your
car washed today it might be the same I don't
think it's a song we're losing steam because
we gotta get to our final destination bed
um no I had said a special shout out because
I was going to give a shout out to oh yeah
special but then you wanted to shout out the
car wash lover because that is the weirdest
you said a lot of weird stuff here that's
easily the weirdest I did you say often weird
things here and that is easily me never who
we shouting out I think you should shout out
Flav Doran and you got to do your Boston shout
out let's go flow
Boston no it's just like Flavor Flav but Flavor
Flav nice no it's wicked [__] Flav it's
wicked cool Wicked Flav Wicked Flav f f is
for foot long Franks at the at Fenway Park
just for family park honestly that was just
a Fenway uh L is for the long trip that it
takes to get back to Boston from La it's very
long and I'll be making it soon e is for extraordinary
the whole city is just extraordinary babe
uh V is for um vagina yeah it's the best Poon
in all the lands let's go go Boston go Flav
that's what I'm talking about go socks go
Flav do you need to do the face when you do
the Boston accent yeah you got it because
this is the way that it is you know everyone
in Boston looks no because there's like a
cute Boston accent too what is it it doesn't
exist
I always read it on the list of the ugliest
accents and I'm like I can't deny it that
is right uh Flav thanks for being a patron
man and thanks for doing it up with us you
know what I mean yeah I'm already uh yeah
you're ready to go oh my God you just yawn.com
yeah I did I'm ready my link Cuisine Pizza
you gotta pack yeah okay yeah my final destination
has come until it's yours to an end we will
see you guys for the fifth one at some point
until then like comment subscribe all that
good good thanks for sitting through this
one with us and we'll see you next time
foreign